je tiens à vous rappeler que si vous
êtes ici c'est parce que plus personne
ne veut de vous la vérité c'est que la
société
sans oublier bien sûr vos familles ont
cessé d'avoir confiance en vous ces
gosses ne sont qu'une bande de vauriens
son coeur j'ai un truc à contrer en
particulier le célèbre ordre du nid du
corbeau il y en a partout dans
l'internât il se passe quelque chose
il se passe de drôles de choses ici et
si jamais ça venait à se savoir
je suis prête à parier que ça ferait
scandale dans cette congrégation somme
investie d'une mission celle de lutter
contre le démon le démon sait exactement
quoi faire pour que nous b sur notre
garde et le mâle donne lieu à des
vilains explicable à des disparitions
le diable est absolument partout lorsque
les portes de l'enfer se décide à
sourire
c'est le mal qui règne alors en maîtres
et regarde